um yo well congratulations because uh I
heard you sold out the Palladium
definitely which is a big deal man
because um really I saw a young thug and
MGK there in 2019. I saw and they that
was their tour together I saw Nipsey
headline there it's our variety headline
that's a big deal man um how is this
tour kind of like
been for you like being the main dude
and doing the size venues you're doing
now it's got to be pretty dope to just
see the the people growing with you yeah
100 is definitely [ __ ] me up I ain't
gonna lie it's been fun as hell but it's
just like like
I did like two tours before this and
they was crazy I did it with my family
so like I was able to learn how to do it
and like doing it myself is like I know
what to do but every night seeing them
[ __ ] be there like my fans I'm like
yeah what the [ __ ] [ __ ] kind of like
crazy right and then it's like they my
fans but they support the whole like
world like opium like right homicide
come out it's crazy like it's just it's
just like bro we got like a whole like
Community like this [ __ ] weird it's just
fire I don't know my [ __ ] my tour been
the best [ __ ] I ever did in my life all
right how would you describe your live
show for anybody who hasn't seen it
it's an experience yeah it's like that
simple are you like [ __ ] crowd
surfing are you [ __ ] hell yeah
jumping in the crowd on the second day
did I just let somebody jump and cry
yesterday because it was their birthday
and then I'd be like I should be wild
they're doing mosh pits and [ __ ] my
speech they singing They dancing these
girls it's a bunch of different stuff
going on you ever get dropped crowd
surfing like Drop nah people don't drop
me it's me everyone's gotten dropped nah
I think uzi's been dropped before what
are we talking about [ __ ] get
dropped you jump in the wrong part of
the crowd some [ __ ] kid's not ready
oh [ __ ] you hit the floor I feel like
but then you can pick back up
listen I [ __ ] crowd surfed a lot in
my day like I write [ __ ] punk rock
shows and [ __ ]
from the crowd's perspective you always
go find if you're at a rock show and
you're in Arizona
you go to the there's always a crazy
native [ __ ] that's the size of a
mountain shout out to my Native American
brothers and sisters out there they love
metal shows you find the biggest dude
and you're like hey like you gotta get
the big dude to lift you up but when you
just jump unexpectedly from the stage
your [ __ ] might be checking
their text fighting with their girl I
ain't gonna lie I only weigh like 150 a
[ __ ] better catch me you make a drop
though man nah bro don't waste that on
me please but you won't get hurt you'll
be right actually I take that back
yellow wolf got dropped and he um he
ruptured his spleen in like 2012. so be
careful that's horrible yeah be careful